it has been two years since Apple
released their M1 Apple silicon powered
Max but there are still people who are
buying and using Intel models for
specific reasons so I'm going to go over
every way that Intel powered Max are
better than Apple silicon starting off
with some simple ones that I thought I
already knew but I guess not and the
first one is the fact that the cheaper
MacBooks only support One external
display now even the 2012 MacBook Air
that I showed off can support two
displays if you daisy chain them and
most MacBooks would support at least two
or more but now you have to spend at
least two thousand dollars to be able to
support more than one external display
with a Macbook and that is the 14 inch
model now I thought for sure the M2
chips will support two and that was a
limitation with the original M1 but nope
the M2 also doesn't do that and of
course if you want to hook up external
Graphics units well you also cannot do
that with apple silicon so some people
are sticking with older ones to have
desk setups that have more powerful
graphics and multiple displays now the
second one has also got to do with the
connectivity and that is the speed of
USB connections now with the original
m1s we discovered that the ssds that we
had connected weren't transferring as
fast both with five gigabit per second
and 10 gigabit per second and that is
still the case with M1 but even with M2
the connections and transfer speeds are
not as fast as with Intel based on the
bandwidth limitations that they have
there now for most people it's not a
huge deal and Thunderbolt does work
really fast but that is definitely a
downside where much older MacBooks that
are Intel based will be faster now the
next one is app support now while many
apps have been updated a lot of creative
apps photo editing video editing Works
Lightning Fast And even some plugins
have been fixed there are still apps
that do not work or not optimized
there's a website called is Apple
silicon ready and they have a list of
different apps that are not working
properly or are not optimized even two
years later now with that there are many
professional applications that simply do
not run and these are programs that
people use for a living for example I
have a friend that does cabinets and
even though he loves Macs he can't use
him he has to go for Windows options so
for his designing he is out of luck now
some applications have been released for
Mac OS for example we have AutoCAD that
is available with a new update for 2023
but with that it is not an apple silicon
version it is running using Rosetta so
even if it shows up you want to make
sure that it's optimized so you get full
performance some of these apps will show
up that they can be installed on Mac OS
but if you actually look down they say
you need to be running boot camp which
we'll talk about in just a sec second
now some of you have heard about the
memory leak issues and unfortunately
with Monterey we are still having that
for example Final Cut here using 70 gigs
of memory now we have had this with
various applications some are not
optimized and it slows your whole
computer down now fortunately there is a
great way to help this and speed up your
Mac check out our sponsor clean my Mac X
which I started using about three years
ago because it is a simple but powerful
app that takes seconds to install and
use their assistant provides
personalized tips and smart scan will
automatically clean up protect and speed
up your Mac in seconds which removed
almost 10 gigabytes of my junk files you
can also dive deeper where I found a
bunch of files that I didn't need along
with malware protection and removal in
an installer that doesn't leave leftover
files and categories as apps so I could
easily see what I haven't been using as
well as an easy to use Auto updater
optimization and maintenance gives you
control to easily fix your system and
space lens is super cool visually
showing me large files where I found a
55 gigabyte phone backup that I deleted
plus they have a shredder to securely
delete sensitive files clean my Mac X
has been very helpful to have and I
really like their menu which shows a ton
of system info along with tools like
memory free up with just one click
cleanmymac is also giving a 20 off
discount for the first two weeks after
this video is released just make sure to
use our download link down below now I
mentioned app support but what about
gaming two years later and we really
don't have much better Solutions now
there have been a couple games that have
came out that are optimized for Apple
silicon but in general most of the games
even Mac games don't run as well on
Apple silicon as they do with Intel
MacBooks and that is because just
because it can open up does not mean it
is optimized for arms so you could be
running on Mac but not optimized for arm
and especially with MacBooks and Macs
have more powerful Graphics especially
the M1 Max and the ultra you do not get
the proper scaling whereas with the M1
when that came out it's a weaker
Graphics so we kind of expected that
performance with that there's not a lot
of games for Mac so some people will run
parallels and while perilous has been
updated to take better advantage of
Apple silicon it still does not run
games very well now we also have
crossover which does a better job and it
can run a lot more games it does a
better job at running them but once
again those games have to run through
multiple layers of translation using
Rosetta which once again the scaling
does not work as well because they're
not natively written for Apple silicon
now for applications you guys saw that
they're suggesting you can run on Mac
but use bootcamp but of course we do not
have bootcamp and that is one thing that
I still wish that we had it was so great
to be able to log in into Windows be
able to do all your windows apps that
run properly and then go back into Mac
OS for those applications but we do not
have that now parallels we recommended
it we show the performance difference
but with parallels you have to run the
windows arm preview which means that it
also does not run Windows applications
as well as normal Windows would so when
you're doing that you have more layers
of translation and even though it's
usable when you do things that need the
performance like for example AutoCAD or
the other applications that will not run
it just does not run as well as it would
on an Intel powered Mac we also have
some more Hardware limitations that
Apple has not yet addressed the first
part of that is Ram now with a more
expensive MacBooks you can get up to 64
gigabytes of RAM even in a 14 inch and
that is really really nice to have now
of course that's limited to the higher
and ones but for the base ones we are
still pretty capped for example with the
Mac Mini they have not updated that to
the M2 so we're still stuck at 16
gigabytes of RAM whereas the Intel model
which they still sell you can actually
have 64 gigabytes of RAM in that and it
was user upgradable so it was cheap with
a 13-inch macro Pros you used to be able
to get 32 gigs of RAM with the M2 Chip
you can get 24 gigs now so it's closer
but not all the way there and of course
with the Mac Pro which they have not
updated yet well you can go up to I
think one and a half terabytes of ram so
people that need that Ram well they
still want to stick with an Intel based
version along with that there's no apple
silicon Max that can support PCI slots
not only for graphics but also for
things like black magic cards that
certain companies need and there's other
PCI cards that can help in different
ways and so people are still buying
playing Mac Pros for those kind of tasks
so we still have to wait for that and
with that one Mac that we are waiting
for is the 27 inch iMac the apple is for
some reason still stalling on we did a
whole video on this and the different
prototype versions that have came out
and I've been in testing and we would
just love to have an all-in-one iMac
with a 27 inch screen that had some
pretty good performance and the ability
to have higher amounts of ram as well
now that Mac Mini that I mentioned that
thing also supported for Thunderbolt
ports for a price tag that was pretty
low now you can get the Mac Studio but
that comes in at two thousand dollars or
above so if you guys see a trend here
where if you want to get better
performance or more ports more
flexibility you gotta cough up some more
money now now the next thing is prices
now of course the M1 MacBook Air is a
killer machine at a great price some of
the stuff has gotten more expensive the
M2 MacBook Air also the 14 and 16
inchers
um the 14 inch is two thousand dollars
so you're spending some more money that
way uh but the Intel models have dropped
a ton in price you can get the i7 Mac
Mini that supports each gpus and has
four thinello ports for 600 bucks now on
eBay and as far as MacBooks they have
dropped like a rock for example you can
get a 2018 MacBook Air for some crazy
low prices and not only with low storage
for bidding but also buy an owls with 16
gigs of RAM and this is the model that
had a fan that ran pretty well so if you
want to get a great deal the Intel
options are much less expensive now and
the last one that I have is the ability
to have a thin and light large screen
MacBook now the 15-inch MacBook Pros and
even the 16 inch were a lot thinner than
the 16 inch Apple silicon M1 Pro 91 Max
model of course Apple gave back some of
the ports they made it powerful but a
lot of people have been complaining that
it's a little too thick and heavy for
them there's even a pole that Luke miani
did that people said they had to get a
14 inch if you can get the same
performance because the 16 is just too
big and when we ran a pole recently A
lot of people said they got a larger
screen MacBook because they just wanted
a larger screen size so personally I
would love to have a 15 inch MacBook Air
that is thin and light has great
performance but doesn't cost as much Ian
is just much easier to take with you so
there you guys go those are the top ways
that Intel Max are still better than
Apple silicon ones now of course overall
the Apple silicon ones are great much
better better battery life features
we've done so many videos about it but
there's still ways that Apple needs to
improve both in software some of the
other capabilities and giving us more
options if you guys have anything else
you guys wanted to mention comment down
below once again check out clean my Mac
X it's a great program uh it has been
very handy to use in its low price check
out the link below click above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right up there this one Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]